Egypt is the mother
of our civilizations denial was like the
the main spiritual path that people took
to understand who they are
so that's why every civilization uh in
the Middle East
went to the Nile to do that process
so from the very first human being that
walked along the Nile understanding
itself in every one of ourselves
we have the Nile path Within because
every human the first humans in the
world in order to expand through the
world had to go through the Nile
so there is no one in the world that had
no cell with the memory of having taken
the path of the Nile
the first human another in another life
you're saying like at some point in time
this
Soul stream essence of human cells all
human cells that exist today in these
eight billion people in the world for
the in order to go to the rest of the
world from Africa they had to walk along
the Nile so in order to go back to the
first path that Humanity took in order
to expand to the outside from the Within
they had to touch the Nile because when
people came from Africa the only way to
cross
to the other side was along the Nile
the only way to go to Middle East to
Europe
to Asia then to Australia then through
Siberians Americas and through the
Pacific Oceans of South America
they all had to cross the Nile so
so where did humans first come from
Human started in Africa okay how did
that happen how did that happen of
course we have been updated I mean right
right we've been genetically modified is
this guy okay
yeah but the main cells the main humans
the first actual humans
were born in Africa and from Africa
they started to expand and they started
to be modified
in Middle East in Siberia uh in the
Americas we have been
in Encounters in constant constant
encounters with other species from other
places that have providers that had
download information into us that had um
but the main species that created the
humans the first cells were in Africa
so that's where the hours our species
appear so we so the base so there's a
there's a part of
the this human
experience that is native
yeah there's a part is that just sort of
the
the cell's learning process of like
creating the organs and then it just
kept expanding and growing and
naturally
the first thing was naturally in this
world but naturally is
it's very weird to say because
um our design
was
created from the sixth dimension
so
some sometimes the thing is
when we say aliens
created humans
we usually tend to to think that aliens
use the same thing
as a human would use to create a species
like
taking a rabbit
taken to a lab
modify something make a mix in a
Mile in a vial whatever and then put it
in syringe in it and wait for it to
transform or open it and change
something inside so that's how humans
would do it
but
people from other
places right other dimensions
from other worlds they don't usually
travel from one world to the another
they use inter-dimension
realities in order to do something
so basically there are many species that
never visit
this world but they modified the life in
this world through the sixth dimension
because we're existing on all these
planes right like
exactly and there are some species in
other worlds that evolved to be able to
to mold and to use the sixth Dimension
and in the sixth Dimension there is no
no space
so
in order to transform the Earth you
don't need a space a spaceship to come
to Earth
you just have to you just have to enter
the frequency of Earth and from where
you are modify the plant and the plant
will modify here through layers of time
so for them it's just a second
but for the for the Earth it could take
a million years yeah until the light is
modified
so that's why what we see as evolution
is actually a lab work in other planets
you know uh so why don't they just why
are why do we not get modified to the
point that we
are incapable of evil and destruction
and
disharmony why wouldn't we get modified
modified up
we need a glow up
yeah it's basically it's like saying for
example
um
I want an apple but I don't want to wait
for the tree to grow
so you can have made an apple
you have to wait for the seed
to be in the darkness and the pressure
of the earth to feel how to absorb the
nutrients and extend roots and first the
first thing that every being does in the
vegetal realm what is to go deep into
the darkness yes darkness is the one
that has the minerals the dark is the
one that has the potential
and you find the dark and the potential
through going against the force of the
earth and you have to feel the pressure
until you feel you are tight enough to
this reality to start growing up
so when you take the
the understanding of how a plant grows
you will understand why in order to
become an aware human being you first
have to go deep into the darkness
is it true then
that kind of like I was saying if we
hold all the information it's just like
system overload like we
we're not capable of taking the upgrade
needed to get to that space
we are doing it right right but like I
mean in an instant we're not capable of
if you if you do it in an instance if if
you do it in an instant uh there's no
experimentation without experimentation
there's no Integra Integra in
integration yeah
there is no Transcendence so basically
you are breaking all the laws of time
and space in the third dimension
and it doesn't make any sense
for the third dimension so actually the
thinking would be why to even exist
you'd be useless back to your original
you'd be useless obviously and there's
only one fun thing for an eternal being
to do
which is to limit itself
that's the only fun thing to do yeah
it's like if you're at Limitless
the only fun thing to do to put a limit
yeah it's like death like if you didn't
if you never died you wouldn't give life
much purpose exactly actually there is
no purpose so we had to invent the idea
of end to have a purpose
so that's why we created the idea of
evil
to understand the light
we have to practice the bad things in
order to understand what is harmony if
you don't go through the stage of
listening I don't know very hard metal
music
you won't understand the balance of a
high frequency music for example right
and neither of them is fine
neither of them is the good one
so what's happening it's just different
frequencies to tune in and to experience
so I mean again back to that like
medicine Journey it was like you're just
here to experience it
exactly so for the universe actually
evil doesn't exist
the the universe doesn't understand
the universe doesn't understand good
that's that's just something that we
created in order to know how to survive
evil can kill you so it's better not to
do evil it's better to do good things in
order to survive and doing the right
thing and the good thing brought us to
create real religions for us to create
culture for us to create patterns that
we are afraid of breaking so we are
trapped in the system because we are a
threat because we have to do the right
thing so what is the right
you know so so that then you start to
think oh maybe doing the right thing was
not the right thing
because we got trapped in our own system
so now we have to break it and we are
the bad guys because is we have to break
the system right right right right yeah
so so that's why what is bad what is
good and basically for the loss of the
universe and that thing actually is when
you break
the Free Will of others
and what is the what is the Free Will of
others the Free Will of others is
basically to allow the other
to exist
uh to allow the other to exist basically
when you kill someone or when you
um take the freedom from someone you're
breaking the balance of that someone
for example for for nature uh it's not
bad to kill when you need energy to eat
that's why all nature does this because
it's something natural
um but there's nothing in nature
actually that that actually create
slavery for example when when you start
to see the actions of evilness
um
in nature is when you start to see the
dissonance of that reality
because actually nature can kill because
of the need
but cannot kill because of a will
so only mind can kill because of a will
and uh when you are when you are
becoming aware that you can kill for fun
or that you can
do chaos taking life of others because
of fun then you start living the process
of this harmony with the environment
with nature and that's why a lot of
other white cells of the body starts to
fight back that cancer
it's like the immunological system the
white cells and we call it light beams
that actually are white cells of the
body so it's the immune system of the
body that suddenly runs towards the
cancer and the cancer basically tries to
get the cells and
and the body tries to survive and if the
body doesn't survive it will it will
give
the information of how to do it next
time in the next body
if you like this clip and you want to
hear the whole episode click at the
bottom of your screen